Alors aujourd'hui on est la pour quoi ?pour parler d'une histoire Incroyable! oh il crie à la 4è secondes de la vidéo oh  Squeezie c'est chiant il est comme avant il est  hyperactif tait toi !
les amis aujourd'hui on va parler d'une histoire mais qui fait pas peur un peu mais pas comme la dernière fois "Le  dire David" d'ailleurs ce nouveau format de vidéo vous avez
trop plu quand je décortiquer un peu thread et que je l’illustre au montage
un thread je sais toujours pas comment on dit , allez on élucide ce mystère (google traduction prononce le mot thread ) .
Je suis tombé sur un autre  (google traduction parle a la place de squeezie ) thread d'un certain Manuel Bartual .
il a fait son thread en  espagnol mais heureusement pour nous quelqu'un a traduit tout le thread en anglais  heureusement pour vous quelqu'un ici va traduire pour vous en français
Lancer moi  des fleurs allez y. Oh  oui cette fois c'est pas une histoire de d'enfants morts qui revient mode  esprit
qui hante ton appartement , non c'est pas comme la dernière fois la ça parle d'autre chose c'est une autre thématique ça fait flipper mais c'est
pas pareil donc normalement vous pourrez dormir cette nuit la bonne nouvelle
alors l'été dernier en août 2017,  Manuel Bartual décide de partir en vacances quelques jours dans un hôtel juste à côté de
plage tout était magnifique il a même mis une petite photo de l'endroit où il passait ses vacances c'est merveilleux c'est tout ce qu'on aime et bientôt
vous y serez peut-être qu'en tout cas je vous le souhaite il était tranquillement en train de lire sur la terrasse de sa chambre d'hôtel
lorsque d'un coup sa porte de chambre s'ouvre et quelqu'un rentre
inutile de préciser que manuel était en vacances seul pour décompresser un petit peu de la vie il était solo alors il se dit putain
c'est sûrement quelqu'un du room service ou qui veut changer les draps ou quoi et j'ai oublié de mettre le truc ne pas déranger
bon c'est ma faute mais pas du tout en allant dans sa chambre il découvre un homme fin et grands qui arpente la pièce.
là ça commence à faire peur je vous  l'accorde  manuel est un peu rassuré parce que le mec n'a pas l'air agressif il a juste
l'air paumé  genre il sait  pas ou il est  du tout alors manuel s'approche de lui pour lui parler et la il lui choppe  le bras manuel sursaute
et le gars se met a  lui parler  très très vite mais ce qu'il dis est totalement incompréhensible
(Siri se met a parler subitement ) je n'ai pas vraiment parler de ces catégories arbitraires
J'étais bien là j'ai peur d'un coup  là fils de pute de Siri  qui s'activent tout seul au début manuel pensait  qu'il parlait dans une autre langue
mais petit à petit il se mit  à reconnaître des mots et en fait c'est juste que le gars ne parlait pas avec les mots dans
le bon ordre  on aurait dit qu'il zappait un mot sur deux et qui mixait des phrases c'était très bizarre sa manière de parler
le mec regarde derrière lui et puis part et manu réalise que le gars il avait une carte de chambres d'hôtels dont probablement une carte qui
pouvait ouvrir la chambre de manu  ce qui est terrifiant tu as vraiment pas envie que des inconnus ait  une carte qui ouvre ta chambre d'hôtel quand t'es à l'hôtel
on est d'accord la manu a un réflexe très humain il verrouille sa porte il se pose sur le canapé en mode putain qu'est ce qui
vient de m'arriver  tu sais c'est choquant quand  ça t'arrive un truc comme ça et il fonce à l'accueil de l'hôtel pour dire putain il y a un
mec qui a accès à ma chambre c'est quoi ce bordel il leur dit qu'à leurs avis c'est probablement
l'ancien locataire de cette chambre là et qu'ils ont oublié de rendre inefficace sa carte c'est un système magnétique que tu pilotes par ordinateur que
tu pilotes je suis vieux c'est bon c'est officiel l'hôtel ça leur paraît bizarre quand même c'est pas un truc que tu oublies c'est limite
le premier truc que tu fais quand quelqu'un fait le check out en partant de l'hôtel
alors il se met à décrire l'homme il leur  dit voilà il est grand il est fin il a des cheveux courts et la meuf de
l'accueil dit à manu de regarder derrière lui parce que le mec était juste là en fait donc tout le monde fait un petit rire
nerveux ils
réinitialise les cartes comme ça y'a que la carte de manu qui ouvre la chambre de manu et c'est très bien comme ça et l'histoire
finit bien. pour le  moment on est bien on est bien je vous dit  vous allez dormir cette nuit  faites moi confiance !
manu nous dit aussi qu'un deuxième truc bizarre lui est arrivé dans la journée il a perdu un t-shirt voilà ça le fait chier il nous met une petite
photo du t-shirts
c'est  pas si terrible qu'il l'ait perdu vue le t-shirt mais ça c'est les goûts vestimentaire c'est autre chose. c'est l'après midi manu descend
pour manger et là il voit le fameux mec qui était entrée dans sa chambre à quelques tables de lui au réfectoire
(soupir) réfectoire pff  au self je suis bloqué au lycée c'est fou pour que ce soient bien compréhensible et plus simple a  raconté on va l'appeler martin cet homme en
passant devant martin martin le salut et s'excuse devant lui et cette fois ils parlent clairement avec chaque mot parfaitement dans l'ordre contrairement à dans
la chambre en gros il s'excuse d'être aller dans la mauvaise chambre il   s'est trompé il est dans une autre chambre et ça lui fait
chier d'avoir fait peur à notre ami manu donc il s'excuse c'est un homme gentil
et le mec il arrête pas dire à manu
t'inquiète  tout va bien avec un petit sourire bizarre sur son visage il en fait des caisses le gars est ce petit sourire ça met
vraiment mal à l'aise manu, il avait limite plus peur à ce moment là que quand le mec est entrée dans sa chambre
manu prends ses couilles a deux mains il prend une photo de lui de loin et le gars ressemble à ça
Bon la y'a rien qui fait peur c'est un mec quoi (rires)
c'est vraiment un mec qui a les cheveux courts et qui est en vacances manuel passe la matinée sur la plage en rentrant dans sa chambre il
trouve par terre un
petit crayon de papier qui
apparemment est un peu usés c'est à dire qu'on a écrit avec alors il se dit que c'est sûrement quelqu'un de l'hôtel qui est venu
changer les draps et qui a fait tomber ça sans faire exprès mais après ce qui s'est passé la veille avec notre ami martin il
ce chie un peu dessus manu , manu décide alors d'aller marcher et il donne pas de nouvelle à voir le soir où il nous dit qu'il marchait sur
la plage et qu'il a décidé d'aller sur un ponton ou  il y a toujours plein de gens qui prennent des photos il décide d'aller au bout
du ponton et en regardant derrière lui qu'est ce qu'ils voient des gens parmi lesquels se trouve
martin on voit pas clairement à cause du contre-jour mais manu nous dit qu'il est certain que c'était martin avec un autre homme qui était
en train de l'observer
(tousse)  c'est glauque ! qui décide alors d'aller les voir et au moment où il se met à marcher vers eux ils font demi-tour et ils  partent ce qui lui fait
le plus peur c'est que l'homme qui accompagnait  martin il portait  le t-shirt que manu a perdu la veille il avait donc aucun style
puisque ce t-shirt est dégueulasse il revient il nous donne des nouvelles en nous disant qu'il trouve qu'il a un peu paniqué que ça se
trouve martin s'était pas du tout l'un des deux mecs qui étaient sur le pont que l'autre c'était juste un hasard qu'il est le même t-shirt
bref il rationalise le truc parce que ça fait quatre jours qui lui est rien arrivé donc il commence à être re un peu en
confiance il décide alors d'aller se détendre en nageant à la plage et à son retour il nous dit qu'il s'est passé un truc
il dit qu'en sortant de l'eau il est tombé sur un mec qui portait le même t-shirt que celui qu'il a perdu et là il a l'impression
de reconnaître cette personne
puisqu'il pense que c'est celle qui accompagnait martin sur le ponton il décide alors de le prendre en photo à deux reprises
il finit de manger il paye il quitte le bar manu prend vraiment en filature notre ami inconnu il le suit jusqu'au supermarché dans
et la manu pète un câble et prend une vidéo du mec et il se trouve que le mec a exactement la même
gueule que manu pour nous aider manu mais une photo de lui juste derrière et effectivement c'est troublant ils se ressemblent énormément
il perd sa trace en sortant du supermarché et il est vraiment choqué le manu parce que la zone elle est tout petite il y a
genre un bar un restaurant  l'hôtel la plage
il n'y a pas grand chose à faire à côté il nous dit que ce mec-là sa journée c'était aller à la plage juste derrière
on l'a vu il a commandé un burger et un soda et juste derrière il est allé acheter de l'eau au supermarché et ce qui
a énormément
stressé manu c'est que c'est
exactement ce que manu a fait le premier jour ou il est  arrivés là dans le même ordre manu rentre à l'hôtel il ya cette histoire de
crayon de papier  qui le stresse il a retrouvé sa au milieu de sa salle de bain il sait toujours pas ce que ça foutait là
qui l'a mis là alors la nuit il se met à chercher où le gars aurait pu écrire et il trouve
Alors sur du pq oui c'est drôle sauf que manu et rigole pas trop parce que ça monte qui a vraiment quelqu'un qui est venu
dans sa chambre mais qui a marqué un putain de truc et manu dit un truc très vrai il dit si quelqu'un voulait me dire
quelque chose et qui voulait qu'il y ait que  moi qui le  lisent ya aucun meilleur endroit que marquer ça dans le rouleau de pq mais c'est vrai alors
manu déroule complètement le rouleau au cas où et s'aperçoit qu'il ya des mots marquer sur chaque feuille il place les mots dans un ordre
qui veut dire à peu près quelque chose selon lui mais il demande de l'aide aux gens parce que c'est bizarre ça lui rappelle la
manière dont le gars qui venait dans sa chambre lui a parlé alors sa communauté l'aide à résoudre ce putain de mystère du pq et
même si à des mots qui peuvent être changés  ça garde du sens globalement la phrase c'est ça tu es en danger il n'y a
plus aucun espoir pour moi mais tu peux encore te sauver va dans l'autre chambre et ne la quitte plus ce n'est pas une blague
putain le coup de pression sa mère le message c'est vraiment un putain
d'avertissement alors ça le stress parce que dans le meilleur des cas c'est une
prank  très élaboré d'un mec et c'est très traumatisants de dire putain quelqu'un entrer dans ma chambre et a écrit ça pour me
pour me faire peur et  me faire un canular ou alors c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui veut m'avertir d'un truc et c'est encore pire donc notre
manu là il est en pls vraiment manu se met alors à penser qu'il ya deux martin pourquoi il pense ça alors que c'est la
même personne physiquement parce qu'elle parlait tellement différemment quand il a vu dans sa chambre par rapport à quand il a vu au breakfast qu'il
est convaincu que c'est pas la même personne sa chambre est au
328 il se dit que la seule autre chambre qu'on peut faire avec les numéros 3 2 et 8 ce serait la chambre
238 c'est la seule possibilité puisque dans l'hôtel n'y a pas de chambres huit cents et quelques manu prend alors son courage à deux mains
il décide d'appeler cette chambre est une femme décroche et parle en  allemand  "allo" et il pense alors que c'est une fausse piste et que
ça doit être une autre chambre dont le message parle manuel va se coucher le lendemain matin il va se balader
l'après-midi reste dans sa chambre se reposer repenser à tout ça ça stresse beaucoup il nous explique que sa chambre à vue sur l'une des
deux piscines de l'hôtel et il ya un truc flippant et dit qu'il est convaincu d'avoir vu l'autre manuel
l'observé depuis la piscine ce qu'il appelle l'autre manuel c'est le mec il a suivi jusqu'au supermarché plutôt auparavant et qui lui ressemble énormément il
décide de prendre une vidéo pour nous montrer ça et il prend soin d'éteindre la lumière de sa chambre avant pour pas que l'autre manuel
le voit
oh c'est flippant ! manu se  précipite sur son téléphone et décide d'appeler l'accueil de l'hôtel pour les prévenir qu'il ya un mec qui l'espionne  depuis la piscine
et que ça m'inquiète beaucoup après avoir passé le coup de fil et retourne à sa fenêtre est là l'autre manu a
disparu il est plus devant la piscine et quelques minutes plus tard l'accueil de l'hôtel le rappelle ils lui expliquent qu'ils ont envoyé quelqu'un pour
aller voir et qui avait personne à côté de la piscine et qu'il a sûrement fait erreur. Manu là il est révolté et il décide d'aller
leur montrer la vidéo qu'il a prise pour leur prouver qu'il y avait bien quelqu'un devant la piscine et que c'est flippant et que c'est pas
normal
malheureusement pour lui ça inquiète pas les mecs de l'accueil qui lui dise  c'est sûrement le mec qui s'occupe de la piscine ou quelqu'un
de l'hôtel qui juste se baladait  bref ils ne prennent pas du tout manu au sérieux et manu ça le rend ouf
à partir de là il n'y a pas de retour en arrière possible pour manu peu importe si c'est une blague ou si c'est réel
il a juste envie de comprendre ce qui se passe de comprendre ce qui lui arrive ça le rend dingue et c'est normal et nous
mêmes si on  était victime de trucs comme ça on aurait envie d'élucider le mystère parce que ça rend ouf ! son hôtel se trouve à une
extrémité de la route manu a marché jusqu'au bout de cette route est à
l'extrémité de la route se trouve un hôtel très similaire au sien qu'il  prend en photo et
effectivement c'est carrément la même chose mais à l'envers c'est comme si chaque hôtel était le
reflet de l'autre on se croirait dans strangers things bordel en arrivant à l'accueil de l'hôtel il tombe sur une femme qui lui parle un
petit peu de la même manière dont
martin lui parlait  dans le réfectoire manu lui demande alors si elle est au courant de l'existence de l'hôtel qui est très similaire au sien
de l'autre côté de la route et si c'est une chaîne si les hôtels sont reliés en fait la meuf esquive vraiment le sujet elle
lui dit juste  t'en fait pas tout va bien un zen on est en vacances manu ça le fait flipper et décide de rentrer à son
hôtel et de demander à l'accueil s'ils sont courants que il ya un autre hôtel de l'autre côté de la route avec une meuf qui
est un peu bizarre à l'accueil les gens d'accueil répondent qu'ils ont aucune idée de la possible existence d'un autre hôtel qui ressemble en plus à
celui là de l'autre côté de la route la manu se dit attends c'est a 3
km il devrait totalement savoir si y'a un autre hôtel alors il monte dans sa chambre il réfléchit
et là il se dit putain mais si le message qui me dit d'aller dans l'autre chambre mais d'y rester
parler de la chambre 328 de cet autre hôtel de l'autre côté de la route
il a une  sorte de déclic le manu il se pose au bar de son hôtel et réfléchi et se dit qu'il va juste y aller tranquillement
toquer attendre  que quelqu'un réponde et demandé des explications à cette personne sur ce qui est en train de lui arriver
il y va en tremblant il l'appréhendent vraiment ce qui va se passer il arrive devant l'hôtel et décide de rentrer il passe l'accueil et
il se rend compte que tout est exactement comme dans son hôtel à lui sauf que tout est inversé
c'est par exemple pour rejoindre les chambres il faut forcément passer devant la piscine
et  la piscine et sur sa gauche quand il passe devant alors dans son hôtel à lui elle est  sur sa droite il prend l'ascenseur il
arrive à l'étage il nous dit que  normalement pour aller à sa chambre il prend à gauche sauf que la  à gauche c'est un cul de sac il doit aller
à droite tout est inversé par rapport à son hôtel et il se dit putain qu'est ce qui se passe ici bordel ce soir la
manu publie une dernière vidéo de quand il s'approche de la chambre 328 de cet autre hôtel et ce qui se passe est très bizarre
Mais mec il est  où le moment ou t'as toquer  où tu as attendu que quelqu'un ouvre ta complètement paniqué  la une heure plus tard manu est de
retour à son hôtel et nous dit bon je vais vous expliquer ce qui s'est passé oui je sais j'ai pété un câble en arrivant
devant la chambre je sais pas ce  que j'ai foutu mais j'ai juste testé la carte j'avais une obsession avec ça et ça a marché la
porte s'est ouverte alors il est rentré dans l'appart il nous explique que au moment où la vidéo coupe
il s'est avancé et tombe face à
l'autre manuel le mec qui lui ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau l'autre manuel le regard d'un air énervé commence à avancer vers le vrai manuel
et le vrai manuel part en courant parce qu'ils se chie dessus ces grands morts là il réalise que c'est chaud que ça va trop
loin il changent
Je vais  faire un arrêt cardiaque dans cette vidéo mais mon gars j'suis en sueur  la je vous raconte un truc
terrifiant tout seul dans les bureaux parce qu il est 21h il ya plus personne
il ya un putain d'orage  hyper venere  dehors il pleut à torrent putain je vais ouvrir la porte il y aura  Squeezie 2 qui sera derrière c'est sur !
finissons-en bortels il se dit ok c'est mort je reste pas ici plus longtemps il avant son retour le lendemain manuel va a l'aéroports et la
personne a l'accueil  de l'aéroport lui dis bah vous êtes seul parce que vous avez réservé pour 2 alors qu'il a réservé tout seul il
a prit  qu'un billet alors manu il comprend pas il est confus et au final il peut prendre l'avion il rentre dans l'avion et il rentre chez
lui ou c'est fini YES et Squeezie  peut rentrer chez lui aussi car c'est la fin hélas non
et ce qui suit est encore pire en arrivant chez lui le portier lui dis putain vous êtes rentré beaucoup plus tôt que prévu alors
vous avez fait vite et manu comprend pas puisque ça fait une semaine qu'il est parti alors il lui dit mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes
ça fait 7 jours et le portier lui réponds bah non mais que tu es parti a vraiment quelques minutes et en plus de ça
tu m'as laissé un petit paquet a te donné quand tu reviendrais alors tiens je te le donne là manu
il comprend rien il prend le paquet qu'est  pour lui il monte dans son appartement il pose ses affaires il décide d'ouvrir le paquet et il
découvre juste son profil twitter
imprimés et en retournant la feuille et un message qui marque et qui dit arrête d'écrire tout ça , ça  se termine ce soir
tout va bien il se chie dessus alors il décide d'aller acheter à manger il retourne chez lui et là en regardant par la fenêtre
qu'est ce qu'ils voient bah la vidéo sera plus explicite que mes mots
Manu le faux  qui le fixe
oui je l'appelle  manu le faux parce que c'est le faux manu la manu il va voir la police ils leur expliquent ils leur montrent
la vidéo du mec qui le fixe par la fenêtre
ils leur montrent aussi les vidéos qu'il a prises à l'hôtel il dit regardez y'a un  mec qui me suit il me ressemble comme deux gouttes d'eau ça
va pas on dirait mon putain de clone c'est flippant la police le regarde bizarre
le crois pas du tout alors il décide de rentrer chez lui en rentrant chez lui sa poignée elle a changé c'est une porte qui
s'ouvre avec une clé et manu il dit putain j'ai le souvenir de l'ouvrir avec une carte d'hôtel mais c'est impossible parce qu'avant d'aller voir
les policiers j'étais chez moi et en rentrant chez moi j'ai dû ouvrir la porte mais j'ai pas la carte de l'hôtel elle est resté
à l'hôtel la barre en vacances alors comment j'ai fait pour l'ouvrir en rentrant la première fois il commence à péter un câble le con de  manu
putain ils se décident à retourner à l'hôtel en vacances parce qu'il se dit qui va rien résoudre chez lui et que le truc le suit et
il en  peut plus alors ils réserve un vol le lendemain pour repartir à cet autre hôtel et en voulant partir
ils n'arrivent plus à trouver sa porte d'entrée il se met à chercher sa porte d'entrée chez lui la trouve plus il peut plus sortir
de là il reçoit un truc bizarre c'est comme si tout était plus grand mais plus petits à la fois c'est le même endroit mais
tout n'est plus au même endroit par rapport à avant d'un coup il trouve enfin une fenêtre il regarde par la fenêtre et il voit
la piscine de l'hôtel
alors qu'il est chez lui il est rentré chez lui il décide de tweeté une photo de ça pour nous prouver qu' un truc qui
va pas sauf que sur la photo nous on voit juste sa rue on voit pas du tout la piscine la manu dit qu'il entend
quelqu'un chez lui il pense qu'il est pas tout seul il réussit à se réfugier dans une salle de bains elle ressemble pas à sa
salle de bain c'est un autre endroit c'est un mélange entre la salle de bains de la chambre de l'hôtel et sa salle de bain
lui le faux manuel ou la porte de la salle de bains regarde manuel quai au sol sans bouger y comprends pas ce que l'autre
manuel veut il bouge plus et réalise qui n'a aucune solution à son problème que il va y passer mais que peut-être il peut prévenir
le prochain locataire de cette chambre d'hôtel alors il décide de sortir son stylo et trouver un endroit où marquer un message d'avertissement que seul
le prochain locataire pourra lire et il trouve où il pouvait marquer ce message l'histoire recommence encore et encore
et là il écrit un message avec la même manière dont s'exprimer le mec était rentré dans la chambre de manu pour la première fois
les mots sont pas dans le bon ordre
c'est bizarre merci pour tout j'aurais aimé ne jamais me rendre à cet hôtel
si seulement j'avais écouté avant le message de peut-être que j'aurais été sauvés au
Petit débrief pour ceux qui ont pas trop réussi à suivre qui on pas trop compris ou peut-être parce que j'ai mal expliqué je sais pas
cette histoire elle est dure à raconter parce que là on parle pas juste de preuve qu'il ya un esprit qui te hante ce qui
est assez classique hein euh
paranormal activity
Conjuring tout ça on connaît cette histoire la d'esprit de possession démoniaque là c'est différent en fait c'est comme si un mec c'est un peu relier
à strangers things c'est comme si un mec s'étaient retrouvés bloqués entre plusieurs dimensions vous savez il ya plusieurs dimensions plusieurs réalités c'est à dire
je vous l'avais déjà dit  dans une vidéo je crois théorie du complot par exemple dans une autre réalité je suis boulanger dans une
autre réalité vous êtes agriculteur
du coup on suppose simplement que manu est restée bloquée entre deux réalités c'est pour ça que l'espace arrête pas de bouger autour de lui
et que c'est autre manu il a aperçu
prendre sa glace aller faire les courses et bien c'était juste lui le premier jour en fait
et l'histoire se répète en boucle
manu arrête pas d'apercevoir manu ah c'est  génial mais j'ai pas tout expliquer je vous laisse débattre sur ça dans les commentaires mais perso je trouve
que cette histoire elle est géniale sachez que c'est une histoire c'est comme un film mais au final
servian même l'histoire est tellement bien raconté il ya des photos il ya tout ce qu'il faut pour y croire c'est magnifique on s'en fout
que ce soit vrai ou pas je trouve ça génial
2018 pour ça il ya une nouvelle manière de raconter des histoires et que ce soit vrai ou pas à l'arrivée on ressent des choses
et on est content d'avoir lu ça
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer des histoires comme ça si vous en trouvez peut-être que j'en expliquerait d'autre vidéo j'avoue moi j'ai un penchant pour les
histoires d'horreur là c'est entre les deux c'est angoissant mais c'est pas de l'horreur en tout cas j'espère que ça   vous aura plus
n'hésité pas à aimé la vidéo si c'est le cas.Je vous dit à très vite. Je veux pas  rentrer un scout j'me chie dessus je vais prendre un bon uber
allez à bientôt ! Chaos